[Musica]
c'e nappi che si posa su un bottone de
rosa lo succhia e se ne va tutto sommato
la felicità è una piccola cosa
felicità un concetto che cerco di
comprendere di fare mila e che trilussa
simile alle api vivendoci insieme da
vent'anni ho cercato di capire a fondo
questo insetto per capire se c'è una
ricetta se un ape può insegnare ad un
uomo come essere felice
accostare quindi l'ape alla felicità
accostare questo movimento continuo
nello spazio è perfetto nel tempo che la
uefa di fiore in fiore da 40 milioni di
anni ad un concetto di piena
soddisfazione
come se in questo volare che porta con
sé la vita stessa ci sia una chiave di
lettura personale e sociale
l'ape è di per sé in movimento vive
all'interno di una casa che si chiama
arnia che sono queste che vedete
colorate ma il suo lavoro lo conti
all'esterno ha il compito ben preciso di
visitare tutti i fiori che si schiudono
intorno alla loro casa una quantità
inverosimile
pensate che per produrre un kg di miele
devono visitare qualcosa come 3 milioni
di fiori 3 milioni di invisibili tocchi
che lapo effettua su un determinato
ambiente per quel vasetto e ha un kg di
miele che ovviamente l'ape raccoglie e
non produce
ecco questo è un tasto che tocco sempre
con i guanti bianchi perché sembra
qualcosa di assurdo l'ape raccoglie ma
il territorio che produce ecco perché in
realtà il miele è figlio del territorio
esistono infatti diverse razze di api
mellifere in italia abbiamo la razza
ligustica quella che vedete alla vostra
sinistra riconoscibile dalla colorazione
dorata
se ci spostiamo in sicilia però abbiamo
la pena era sicula la ritrovata al
centro di dimensioni più piccole di
colore nero se andiamo nell'acqua
avvicina slovenia la vedete segnata di
bianco abbiamo la razza carnica un po
più grassottella scura e molto molto
docile razze di api diverse per colore
docilità e prolificità
ma che se inserite nel medesimo
territorio
originano il medesimo miele ecco perché
il miele è una fedele riproduzione
zuccheri na di un determinato territorio
e per gli appassionati di fotografia
possiamo assimilare per 3 milioni di
invisibili tocchi che la perfetta su un
determinato ambiente a 3 milioni di
pixel per comporre una fotografia
istantanea di un determinato territorio
in un determinato momento dell'anno
incredibile e quando scopro qualcosa di
incredibile mi piace andare a ritroso
per capire da dove questo sì origini
l'ape e all'insetto sociale per
eccellenza vivono in società hanno
creato la società un'ape da sola non ha
valore ecologico una famiglia d'api e
cioè un gruppo che va da 4.000 a 60 mila
t che vivono all'interno di una colonia
hanno un apporto fondamentale per gli
ecosistemi l'ape crea valore partendo da
un gruppo unito organizzato ma se
andiamo ancora più a fondo vediamo che
in realtà una famiglia non è composta da
60 mila p in realtà è un unico individuo
un superorganismo e come in un corpo
umano in movimento ogni ape a una
cellula che di per sé ha valore solo se
inserita in una determinata posizione di
quel corpo con altre migliaia di cellule
per formare un organo il super organismo
funziona proprio così
ap collegate fra di loro che in maniera
coordinata e simbiotica sono direzionate
verso il futuro verso il proseguo della
specie
questo mi ricorda i racconti di mio
padre del suo secondo dopoguerra
questo e vigne una cittadina in montagna
marchigiana dove è cresciuto mio padre
negli anni 50 200 abitanti oggi nove
famiglie numerose che creavano il loro
valore
cercando di preservare il territorio e
ambiente unica loro fonte di
sostentamento
famiglie unite proiettate al futuro
e questa non è più una situazione che
ritroviamo in italia ma una situazione
che ritroviamo in quei paesi che
definiamo in via di sviluppo proiettati
in avanti in maniera forte tramite la
forza biologica da loro prodotte e
direzionata verso il proseguo della
specie
l'incontro tra l'uomo e la pe cioè da
dall'alba del mondo questa è una pittura
rupestre del 2000 400 avanti cristo dove
c'è un uomo intento o una donna intenta
a raccogliere del miele e in questi
millenni l'api è stata sempre allevata
anche se in realtà all'ape non è né un
insetto domestico è né un insetto
selvatico quindi l'apicoltura in realtà
non è un allevatore di api l'allevatore
a un custode di api
e ogni apicoltore capisce questo fino
allo step finale dei grandi maestri
assecondare in tutto e per tutto la per
la natura infatti funziona perfettamente
senza interferenze esterne la natura
talento ma anche ossessione la
professionalità da quello che fa ed è
proprio questa sessione che l'ha portata
a sopravvivere e far sopravvivere il
mondo intero in questi milioni di anni
molti esseri viventi volano pochi
pochissimi realtà sanno impollinare
l'ingranaggio fondamentale che permette
alla natura di mantenere il conto dei
secoli all'ape basilare quanto
invisibile
ed io fin da piccolo volevo a tutti i
costi farne parte
cari genitori stati molto attenti a
quello che regala dei vostri figli
perché poi questi possono essere i
risultati ma la realtà è sempre diversa
da come la possiamo immaginare la realtà
è che la pena un insetto sociale diretto
e puntuale immortale
immortale in quanto organismo in grado
di autorigenerarsi per secoli per durare
in eterno
ma allo stesso momento
è estremamente aggressivo in determinate
situazioni è velenoso non è caritatevole
e con il quale è impossibile avere un
contatto come se fosse un animale
domestico l'unico modo che abbiamo
trovato per capire al meglio questo
insetto e diventare noi stessi a per
diventare noi stessi
parte integrante del processo rientrando
nei loro ritmi nello stile di vita e
così abbiamo fatto siamo diventati
apicoltori nomadi siamo diventati i
custodi del bene più prezioso e fragile
abbiamo iniziato a viaggiare per
conoscere meglio api e territorio e
anche noi stessi perché a nessuno di noi
passerebbe mai per l'anticamera del
cervello di fare quattro volte il giro
della terra per la produzione di quel
vasetto da kg di miele
150.000 km che le api percorrono
produzione di quel vasetto la mobilità
allo spostamento sono alla base della
vita della pa che sopravvive grazie al
suo volare ogni arnia riesce a visitare
diversi chilometri quadrati di
territorio ma non sempre basta si
all'ape e all'apicoltore ci sono
determinati momenti dell'anno infatti in
cui determinati territori produttori di
miele come dicevamo son e standby non
hanno vero più fiori da offrire alle api
e di conseguenza l'ape soffre soffre
perché non avendo più a disposizione
miele polline va verso un periodo di
stress fisico e questo stress fisico può
manifestarsi con già mature con blocchi
di deposizione da parte della regina con
la morte o l'instaurarsi di patologie
tutte cose che andrebbero a
compromettere le loro eventuali
successivi raccolte un periodo di ferie
dalla raccolta del miele la pelo vive
con stress fisico
quindi
per capire ancora al meglio il tutto ho
capito che dovevo essere ancora più ap
mi impegno mi ossessiona anch'io faccio
di loro la mia proprietà faccio un
ulteriore step e compro un camion con
ladrona
prendo la patente c e inizia a spostarla
in giro per l'italia
a seguire tutte le fioriture di cui
hanno bisogno
siamo apicoltori nomadi transumanti a
tratti veri e propri zingari senza fissa
dimora
al calar del sole
da marzo a ottobre carichiamo le api sul
nostro camion e via come fossimo una
carovana di un circo ci spostiamo su e
giù per l'italia per fargli conoscere i
territori più belli per fargli baciare i
fiori vergini e dar loro la vita
partiamo da taranto per fargli conoscere
tutti gli agrumeti della costa jonica
che poi piano piano risaliamo peak su
per lo stivale
uno dei viaggi più
emozionanti che abbiamo fatto è stato
quando l'anno scorso ci siamo spostati
ad aprile sopra amatrice per la
produzione del miele di tarassaco al di
là delle condizioni climatiche
proibitive e stato un viaggio
emozionante per tutto quello che le apc
hanno voluto raccontare
erano le nove di sera e
ci stavamo apprestando a caricare sul
camion le api che già dall'indomani
avrebbero iniziato a raccogliere miele
di tarassaco le api si possono caricare
solo di notte perché è l'unico momento
in cui sono tutte all'interno della loro
casa ci mettiamo le classiche tre ore
per caricare legare il tutto al meglio
poi un paio d'ore di riposo e alle 3 di
notte si parte
arriviamo all'alba e attraversiamo
quelli che sembravano dei paesi appena
bombardati al quadro del tronto accumuli
rocchetta san lorenzo a matrice
con le prime luci e vediamo una casa
sventrata con quella che era una camera
da letto con ancora l'armadio aperto i
vestiti appesi lampadario penzolante
cresce noi un sentimento di disagio di
di essere nel posto sbagliato
eravamo distrutti
dietro di noi avevamo però delle api che
pensavano così forte da superare il
rumore del camion e dei nostri pensieri
a loro non interessava la distruzione a
loro interessava la rinascita
interessava uscire volare raccogliere a
ridare la vita e portare a casa un po di
miele stavamo attraversando la
disperazione ma avevamo dietro di noi un
qualcosa che ci spingeva in avanti in
maniera violenta
le api avevano sentito prima di noi che
era giunta l'ora di ricostruire
poi la natura matrigna
ma anche madre sa come spaccati in due
il cuore verso le 7 iniziamo a scaricare
le nostre api e vediamo una delle albe
più belle che io abbia mai visto i
terreni ad un certo punto iniziavano a
colorarsi di rugiada gialla frutto
dell'umidita sui fiori di tarassaco già
invasi dalle api che facevano da specchi
al sole sembrava di essere controllati
d'oro e quello era l'unico posto in cui
avremmo voluto essere
o forse era l'unico posto in cui
dovevamo essere perché li avevamo un
senso noi per non dimenticare e le api
per ricostruire e per non dimenticare
noi facciamo proprio questo preleviamo
pezzetti di territorio in tutta italia
tramite il miele tramite il polline e li
facciamo conoscere a più persone
possibili perché dentro quei vasetti c'è
tutta la storia l'amore la disco
frazione di millenni di vita vissuta non
solo dall uomo
forse è qui concludo è proprio questa
sua in consapevolezza del proprio valore
che rende così speciale lab e
perché se ci pensate un attimo l'atto
più rivoluzionario è proprio questo un
superorganismo che appoggia una sua
cellula una semplice app e su un bottone
di rosa e appaga tutto l'universo
grazie
[Applauso]